maybe it would be good to get your
comments your old stomping gr Harvard do
you think the president of har should
have been fired I mean I think she
should have been fired not over the
plagiarism allegations I think she
should have been fired based on her
performance just at that Congressional
hearing uh if if the word black had been
substituted for Jew in in in that
statement by Elise stanic that she was
asking about or trans or or literally
any other any other minority in America
maybe with the exception of Asian uh
then the answer would have been very
different coming from Cloudy and gay you
know with that said I don't think the
fighing of cloud and gay really
accomplishes very much meaning I'm I'm
did she get what she deserved sure does
that mean that the underlying Dei Equity
based system has been in any way
severely damaged no I think that this is
a way for universities this Truth for as
mcil pen also to
basically throw somebody overboard as
the as the sacrifice to to maintain the
underlying system that that continues to
predominate at American universities
where they spend literally billions of
dollars every year on EI initiatives and
diversity hires and diversity
administrators and and all of this I
mean one of the cost of Education
escalating is in the massive
administrative function that that is now
undertaken by universities as opposed to
teaching and and you know clost of dorms
and
such